è da tutti ragazzi prevenuti cose non
visto che voleva vj oggi siamo sul live
view kevin hall ragazzi un gioco che mi
avete martellato per forlì nella maniera
incredibile la cosa che mi incuriosisce
che lakeview kevin che cazzo di stupro è
comunque un importo ragazzina facciamo
finta di nulla andiamo avanti
la cosa che non ho che bello sto tizio
sembra una versione molto più [ __ ] dello
chef tony e ragazzi con che la cosa è
cos'è questa ferrari a 90 e tagliaerba
giusto che non va avanti perfetta non ci
si può sedere sui tagliaerba valori si
può usare perfetto trovato ho trovato un
ascia perfetto trovato ragazzi sto gioco
mi dà già soddisfazione ve lo dico tra
l'altro è uscito un alveare devo rompere
anche questo infatti no cazzo via via
dalla mia [ __ ] faccia sporca scatola
spacco tronco spacco forse faccio
famiglia perché sta diventando tutto
buio ragazzi sta diventato cazzo sta
diventa apposto entrare qui dentro ci
fosse entra qui m che bello
c'è una chiusura a chiave fermi che ho
visto la chiave come cazzo si prende
dava questa questo è un cesso cioè yo yo
ma perché c'è un gesto sul lago giochi
qui arriva la notte entra in un gesso e
calce allora se poi c'è una chiave di
sopra che ancora non ho capito ma chi se
le foto non importa basta che andiamo
via
non me ne frega niente piacere un casino
se difficile a questa è chiuso
fantastico
comunque la cosa che non ha questo
aperto perfetto si deve sia che minchia
ragazzi vorrei viverci qua dentro troppo
figo e ho trovato ho trovato uno
sgabello non cos'è sta roba ragazzi
concorso appreso raga non si capisse c'è
un fucile attaccato al muro ma non
importa perché io questo non importa
andiamo fuori ragazzi allora qualcosa a
qualcuno mi servirà di sicuro perché
sono che cazzo hanno messo a fare tra
l'altro sta tornando giorno e la cosa è
troppo [ __ ] bambi sei tu ti riconosci
ciao bambino dove cazzo vai ragazzi sta
andando sta andando da qualche parte non
so dove i ragazzi mi sembrava di aver
visto madonna o lady gaga una delle due
era subito su sto coso avergli fa
perfetto mandato a [ __ ] la scatola
sono un genio è la cosa anche questa si
apre perfetto c'è un secchio utilissimo
e c'è un altro un'altra scatola un altra
scarpa perfetta che ha capito che cazzo
mi sanno se io io raccolgo robe
non sa cosa ma anche schifo
ragazzi che cazzo ok ho inventato
qualcosa non chiedetemi cosa ma perché
io sono lo chef tony nudo che vomitava
che schifo ma basta pace un ceppo che
non posso però non premi che cazzo mi
servono ste cose che cazzo è cascato una
troppo una trappola però si è cascato di
sicuro non lasciò presto con la roma
deve aspettare un attimo
ok perfetto definivo malissimo sono
sicuro la trappola però se mi spiegate
che cazzo riserve scusate comunque ho
trovato ferma per lurido bambi devi devi
dirmi chi cazzo è ho trovato c'è una
tizia obesa che mi discorre e ciò del
sardo sangue non so perché avrebbe
capisco c'è pochi come non detto è lady
gaga rega e l'etica e lei perché lady
gaga è uscita dal lago fatemi capire ed
evo devo entrare nell eccesso
ok e c'è il sesso sicuro nel frattempo
caso che è inseguito da lady gaga si
metta a cagare in un cesso questa è la
cosa più
gaga sei una stronza o chiare che sono
solo ripartito non spiegatemi perché
hanno tentato di uccidermi dovete
spiegare chi cazzo è quella innanzitutto
poi la seconda cosa sto perdendo sangue
e sto vomitando non ho capito perché
forse perché si è attivata la trappola
non ho capito neanche perché ma non
importa devo devo tipo entrare nel lago
ok no non posso entrare nell'agone anche
da nudo e sto già sanguinando cioè
spiegatemi perché a questo è un binocolo
che io costa roba posso vedere avanti
sta cosa non lo sapevo questa bella
figlia che se li spiaggia venite qui che
se lo chef tony e balliamo dove cazzo
lamento non lo so mettiamo sono un
[ __ ] alla ragazzi c'è c'è
io vado nudo il giro perché vincendo
troppo un figo rom che c'è se bambi che
devo prendere cazzo c'è ok come non
detto l'alveare andato a [ __ ]
devo la cosa che devo fare di sicuro e
prendere bambini mentre scappa è infatti
brutta [ __ ]
devo ammettere sto coso a terra di
sicuro devo farlo a spuntare come faccio
rientro esco
non lo so non ho capito stacco perfetto
non esca è allora che cazzo serve adesso
ci dovrei essere che aspettate un attimo
se si aspetta un attimo perché c'era
c'era una una gnocca nel mio letto oggi
rimarrei volentieri solo chi è sparita
comunque vorrei vedere se le scaricare
quel cazzo di accesso su cavalli io ti
voglio bene
però devo ucciderti grazie è la buona
carne dello chef tony dove credete che
la prenda lo provate tutte ragazzi non
ho capito che cazzo ho ucciso bambi e
quindi siamo poi non è che devo tagliare
la sì ma io posso passare qua sopra
novero mi ammazzo
non mi ammazzo allora che cazzo di steve
sei tu ragazzi col cazzo ma [ __ ]
gaga mi sta portando nel lago st [ __ ]
aiuta
secondo me non si faceva vedere perché
non ero vestito non lo sa perfetto
facevano è un vino è il vino all'atto la
torcia la torcia mia nuova questa non la
sapevo se riesco ad andare
porca [ __ ] ci siamo ragazzi ciò
immettersi da un pezzo
ok ok luca gaga
ho vinto io ragazzi stagione a è morta
ragazzi e porta con sé o finto e il
cazzo se i ragazzi sanno che schifo
oddio che che emerge è che cazzo è
uscito ragazzi aiuto aiuto oggi che
cos'è sta roba
ho trovato più secco la merda aiuto no
no devo prendere lascia dove lascia dove
lancia no agli occhi sono morto così
ragazzi mi sto perdendo tra l'altro non
mi ricordo più porca [ __ ] come si
lancia no no cazzo non adesso
non adesso grosso aiuto vado a dormire
dormi dormi e sta zitto rappo c'è poco
tempo che la [ __ ] sei una [ __ ]
sei una [ __ ] sappi ragazzi qualcuno mi
deve spiegare come cribbio faccio a far
fuori sta qui non si capisce mai vai vai
vai vai vai martini party cazzo vuoi da
stronza son cazzi tuoi
cazzo sono affatto come casa fa ha
ucciso pure due lance è uscito come
cazzo affatto ragazze da bambi perché o
che ci sono ci sono ci sono dai cazzo
dai cazzo cazzo ci credo
ok dovremmo avercela fatta
non lo so non sono convinta aspettate
una più dov'è lascia dove l'omessa
ragazzi mi è sparita non che poi mi
sparisce lascia è questa la cosa bella
come fai come cazzo faccia uccidere il
caso che esce adesso qualcuno mi spiega
come il cazzo faccio a far fuori
qualcosa che li esce dallo stomaco
adesso che non va ma [ __ ]
ok ok ok ok mori devi morire maris
pranzo cazzo come cazzo fatto non lo so
sono andato ho vinto non so neanche cosa
cazzo è successo è successo tutto in una
velocità pazzesca non ci ho capito più
nulla
ragazzi in teoria la mia idea era quella
di prendere lascia quella che c'era
quella che ho usato per uscire bambino
che non c'era più lascia quindi dovuto
ho dovuto arrangiarmi così credo di
averne viste abbastanza per oggi non so
voi comunque servi dove piaciuto cazzo
ma negli occhi schiaccia ma verne
importa sarà un altro finale
comunque non ho capito anche a che serve
la chiave ma vai non impone a chi se ne
fotte
l'importante che sono riuscito rialziste
video è piaciuto come al solito lasciate
un commento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook come la di video tratta nella
descrizione de servery city iscrivetevi
ci rivediamo il prossimo video e da
ragazzi